todos estamos hechos de historias
estamos rodeados
que nos hacen crecer personal y
profesionalmente estamos marcados de
alguna manera por experiencias algunas
extraordinarias y otras no tanto verdad
pero muchas cosas que no podían nos
forman y nos ayudan a tomar muchas
decisiones
yo te voy a
se me rompe acá
que cuando yo tenía 11 años
está
y yo le decía a mi mamá unos niños
platicando en la radio yo le decía mi
mamá no llevame yo quiero ir a ese lugar
mágico donde están esos niños que están
hablando de cosas maravillosas y yo
estoy aquí en mi casa con una caja
mágica en donde puedo escuchar sus voces
mamá llévame y que creen que pasó o sea
obviamente tu mamá viendo a una niña tan
entusiasmada con ganas de hacer radio
pues pues no no me llevo a la radio no
me llevo pero eso no me quito el sueño
de algún día llegar a ese lugar mágico
resulta en mi clon uno de mis compañeros
era conductor de uno de esos programas
yo me super emoción de grecia o si yo te
escuchaba en la radio y bueno cuéntame
cómo se le hace yo quiero estar ahí yo
quiero hacer esa magia y en una
se da la oportunidad de que yo pueda
entrar y pueda conocer esa cabina de
radio y ese fue el detonante de muchas
cosas que vida es el primer programa de
radio yo tenía cuatro compañeros y
hablábamos sobre la red de méxico
hablábamos de los estados la música
el folklore la comida
de toda la república mexicana
tiempo después
formó mi primera pieza que crea sus
propias unidades esa fue la primera
pieza
que me permitió a mí
tener la idea de que podía crear siempre
mis propias oportunidades y hoy a mis 23
años lo sigo haciendo
tuve muchos en la radio prácticamente
crecí en una placa porque hasta la fecha
lo ha estado haciendo
y bueno resulta que pasa el tiempo y yo
quiero hablar ya de otras cosas no ya
haya entró aquí a la adolescencia y tú
se sabe no quiere no hablara y ya de
éste
entonces los novios drogas todo este
tipo de cosas que uno como adolf y te
quiere empezar a conocer experimentar y
ese luego fue
el primer luego de mi primer programa
estaba yo sola
se llama meta fosis porque yo era el
cambio que hacía de mi etapa de mi niña
a la adolescencia
y resulta que tiempo después hay la
oportunidad de entrar a una estación de
radio comercial la que yo estaba era
cultural entonces no podías cometer
muchos muchos temas entonces yo voy hago
en mi primer casting de 14 años
imagínense me acuerdo que cuando llegue
a hacer el casting pues todo se me queda
viendo porque yo llevaba mi uniforme de
secundaria y se me queda a mí no así
como es en serio
tú una niña de 14 años va a venir a
hacer un casting de radio y bueno
obviamente lo hizo fatal porque fue mi
primera experiencia en un casting pero
eso permitió que yo siguiera creando mis
propias oportunidades porque yo ya tenía
una idea o la primera experiencia de
cómo se hacía un casting de radio
pasa el tiempo sino que es oportunidades
y resulta que dos estaciones de radio
estaban haciendo casting para solo seis
personas o sea todos podían hacer
solamente seis personas iban a quedar en
la cabina
el privilegio es que iban a tener un
programa en la hora más escuchada y la
mejor parte es que ibas a trabajar en la
radio y hacer uno de mis grandes sueños
en la radio
y que creen que apartado
y se los dos castings y pase los dos
castings que fue la mejor parte
pero estas dos estaciones descubrieron
un secreto
y por eso me rechazaron
lo que estás
es que era menor de edad
y por eso me rechaza porque ellos
estaban buscando a una persona que fue
de edad para el trabajo
pues ya tuve que
fuera de la red enorme edad continua
y entonces ya entré ya era mayor de edad
pero todavía no podía trabajar porque no
tenía una carrera
y que decidí estudiar ciencias de la
comunicación porque era que me iba a
llevar a ese gran sueño que es la radio
trabajar en la radio
y en este programa
ya desarrollo en un nivel
plato acerca más sociales ya estaba
combinando dos cosas que me gustaba en
mi carrera y la radio y ahora agregaba y
los problemas sociales y estos programas
de radio nosotros hablábamos de tenía
100 ciudad hicieran este programa para
la gente deja tura qué pasaría si se
creara un programa para que la gente
pudiera adoptar perritos por ejemplo
pero era así hipotético que más tira que
pasaría
pero en una ocasión estábamos acerca de
la reforestación en mi ciudad de
tehuacán y nos llama una señora a camina
y nos dice oye yo escuché que usted
estaban hablando de la reforestación la
próxima semana vamos a tener actividad
qué les parece si se vienen y nosotros
más nos apuntamos entonces fuimos
vivimos es es pedir esa experiencia la
platicamos en cabina de radio y fue
maravilloso y ahí fue donde surge mi
segunda pieza de este rompecabezas de
éxitos el ponerte en acción ya crearse
tu oportunidad
ahora ponte en acción no sólo era de
problemas sino experimentar ese problema
y darle a la gente cómo podían apoyar
a estas actividades
estando en la universidad tengo la
oportunidad de unirme a un grupo que se
dedica a la agricultura pero no sólo eso
le aplican la agricultura le enseñan la
agricultura a niños y les enseñan no
solo a cuidar el planeta sino les
enseñan valores les enseñan el respeto
y sobre todo les enseña la gratitud a la
tierra por todo lo que nos ha dado
ya entendí mi tercera pieza de este
rompecabezas porque estoy haciendo las
cosas
esta gran duda y al mismo tiempo que era
una satisfacción el poder compartir este
tipo de experiencias y sobre todo
poder compartirla con niños
en el programa también hablamos de la
adopción a cachorros y en una ocasión
iba yo caminando con una de mis amigas y
nos encontramos a tres cachorritos en la
calle y utilizamos los medios para poder
darles caza
uno de esos perritos es este que está en
la foto
eso no llegó conmigo
y esta foto estas fotos son de dios o
así se llama este perrito product aarón
cayó en una familia maravillosa
y este es todo un año y medio después de
haber sido y compartir estas
experiencias en la radio fue genial
porque la gente llamaba a min aire hacia
oye cómo puedo adoptar un perrito me
gusta mucho la historia que comparten
las experiencias y entonces ahí entendí
mi cuarta pieza cuáles son tus metas
yo quería ir difundiendo los mensajes a
través de la radio para que la gente
pudiera participar y entonces yo pudiera
ya formarme una meta cuál era mi meta
cambiar la vida al menos de un animalito
contando las experiencias
como recordarán mi primer programa de
radio hablaba sobre las públicas
mexicanas
cuando yo entro a otra estación de radio
comercial me encantaba jugar con mis
compañeros a que yo estaba en los juegos
olímpicos y vamos sin cabina mi
compañero decía así estamos en vivo con
mi compañera sandra ella está tomando
todos los datos de cómo va a méxico y
entonces yo del otro lado de la así como
que estaba si estoy aquí transmitiendo
en vivo y en directo desde río de
janiero porque no somos olímpicos así y
era increíble porque la gente llama y
oye si siento que sandra está los jugos
olímpicos y nosotros no es broma es
imaginen que sandra si está de viaje no
era fantástica
pero no me pregunte bueno porque la
experiencia real es
y tomé la mejor decisión de mi vida
comencé a viajar y a raíz de comencé
radio viajes no tiene nada que ver con
sustancias para los rayos solamente es
compartir las experiencias poniendo
sonido les oye hoy vamos a ir a dar
lugar así que imagina que estás en
nayarit por ejemplo
y también
con mis experiencias porque empecé a
recorrer la república mexicana
imagínense y sus pesos que tienen ellos
los 11 años ya lo estaba cumpliendo
cuando ya estaba en la universidad y
estaba en la radio ya tenía muchos de
mis sueños cumplidos y ese era otro que
con el tiempo fui descubriendo
y esta es otra de mis piezas de este
rompecabezas hacer las cosas con pasión
que ya nos han dicho que que es algo
importante porque de qué sirve que ya
sabes cuál es tu meta cómo le vas a
hacer
como ponerte en acción pero de nada
sirve
si no vas a hacer las cosas con pasión
sin duda
dos personas que nos complementan
y mi rompecabezas no estaría completo
tres personas importantes para mí mi
mamá mi papá y mi hermana
mi papá
es como la analítica parte donde tienes
que ser responsable tienes que trabajar
por tus sueños tienes que estudiar mucho
y mi mamá es todo lo contrario mi mamá
es como aquí la diversión
haz lo que quieras no es como relax vaya
y mi hermano mi hermano es cuatro años
mayor que yo y él es la parte que me
empuja a hacer todo lo que yo quiero
y eso es lo bonito porque todos nos
rodeamos de personas que nos empujan que
nos hacen sentir bien que nos hacen
crecer también tengo amigos que no puse
la foto de mis amigos porque se vayan a
poner espesos y que no los puse pero
también los amigos son importante de
cada uno de nosotros porque nos
complementan
y para mí las piezas del éxito
son perfectamente qué pasa cuando un
rompe
tratar de forzarlo
pues simplemente la imagen que quiere
mostrar no va a ser
así que espero que
cuando hagas tu romper esas tomes en
cuenta que has recorrido un camino que
te ha marcado y que te ha hecho crecer
como persona y este estudio es
importante agradecer los resultados yo
nunca pensé pero para mí no existe el
fracaso para mí existe lo aprendido
porque tal vez no resultó como yo
esperaba pero aprendí y entonces tengo
que agradecer ese resultado
así que cuando llegues a casa date
cuenta que eres una mujer que puede
poner todas las piezas que ella desee
siempre y cuando ese rompecabezas esté
completo tienes cosas que te gustan
tienes amigos tienes un trabajo
maravilloso
tal vez haces investigación científica
lo que complemente lo que sea que te
haga feliz lo que sea que cada día
cantante de la cama y luchar tú quieres
debe ir en el rompecabezas
ama ríen juega transforma puesto
monta dinosaurios lo que tú quieras eres
capaz de hacer longitud imagines
porque cada pieza es una pieza de éxito
nos han engañado que el éxito es tener
mucho dinero tener muchos seguidores en
redes sociales tal vez pero no siempre
el éxito
eso es un que te hace feliz eso que te
complementa y sobre todo eso que haces
con mucha pasión
un rompecabezas de éxito
debe estar completo saben por qué porque
somos personas completas
que todas las cosas que nos conectan y
lo que estáis haciendo hoy
va a tener un resultado en 5 o 10 años
pero porque has trabajado por eso porque
le has puesto una pieza tal vez todos
los días porque aprendes le agregas
conocimientos
tienes tus habilidades
así que te invito
a que por favor
es
y le demuestras al mundo tu tienes un
rompecabezas de éxitos porque tú eres
una mujer completa así que ve y
muéstrale al mundo de lo que esta fecha
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]